sup guys my name is Antoinette I play
Paxton or never have I ever
I'm Jaron Lewisohn I played Ben gross
and never have I ever
and today we are reading the loom their
sweets
[Music]
I've weirdly attracted the Jared loosens
arm air and I mean hate then I've made
this discovery about myself that pan
down after the kiss you're a fool
you're a full-on main eye I do have a
lot of armor that he just I don't know
genetics man you know it's funny like
yeah like I've had very self-conscious
moments because like girls in school
would always be like why do you shave
your arms
cuz I've never had like army and I'm
like I don't show my arms living in soon
probably the best thing that happened in
2020 was Darren Barnett tests pecs and
how you shoot it in hashtag never have I
ever
all of 20 I mean 20 20 18 pound scrap
years have been rough so you're you're
definitely out there
all men are gross except for Ben gross
dude I feel really good about that
they're just such a sweet compliment to
start off with it
Davey does say that you're gross gross
she doesn't do that imagine not fun
Darren Barnett attractive how's the lack
of taste I wake up some mornings and I
feel like oh you have a lack of tips I
think that's a fair assessment
sometimes you don't recognize I've seen
your hair get real poofy it's shut up
don't tell them that I just finished
never have I ever on Netflix I must say
that Ben is astronomically more
attractive than Paxson I have a huge
crush on him oh yeah I like and I mean I
agree man you you can't you know and
you're your dad's hot you staying in the
show dude he is he is man that's a good
point
it's good genes Darren Barnett is about
to be the internet's boyfriend you know
what sure I stuck the one who sliced me
with his jaw line anyway that's fine it
I like it though I mean the Internet's
DeGuerin that's a lot of pressure
because Valentine's Day is gonna be like
raise each Ben's been aggressive never
have I ever
he's totally hottest and I can't take my
eyes away from him ah Darren Lewis you
deserve to be recognized and appreciated
you know what you deserve to be
recognized and appreciated too
I still don't know how they found
my creeper account and sound with my
might really sounds like new you might
even be taxing Molly she could break my
heart and you have million pcs and
alcohol miss bacon for me this is
reminds me of like Mean Girls were there
like one time Regina George punched me
in the face it was awesome I love it
like protect yourself protect your heart
you know you gotta respect yourself over
there don't let any big break alright
just finished watching never have I ever
and I'm sure all in agreement that Ben
is 10,000 times the better than passing
right
hello I'm so relieved that baby ended up
with Ben 10,000 times better that's just
a lot of times I mean they really put
thought yet he's ten times he's a
hundred - no no he's in thousand times
that's a that's a big number dude I mean
she's so relieved and I tell you the
truth I mean I I was pretty relieved to
her for Ben but I don't know that
voicemail Paxson's fax it's calling so
I'm gonna beat you in crazy twenties
before season two to try and get my
title back hold on let's let's let's
let's touch on a topic here yeah
controversy you have a girlfriend when
you're kissing another dude I don't know
I thought I saw a really interesting fan
theory the other day there was like a
picture when I opened my when Ben in his
locker in an episode 10 the picture of
Shearer is gone it's there the entire
time and then he opens soccer and the
pictures gone it's just a picture of
been holding pizza I'm starting anyone
out there that believes otherwise but
it's hash tag team Paxton sorry Ben the
tweet said that I didn't say sorry Ben
but also start then Paxton you know
doesn't have a girlfriend bg6 a v-neck
is sailing packs and all use cheetah
whoo I know only one man that's been
gross I mean you do check all the boxes
minutes in terms of like you're rich
you're handsome you got a house to
yourself all the time like oh dude the
hell yeah the houses of the self I don't
know if that was really my choice or not
I think just my parents just weren't
really wanting to hang out with me ever
but uh it's cuz they're jealous
Davey's dad would love past especially
for basically saving her life from the
coyote unless the coyote who's her dad
and he was just trying to give her a hug
and I broke it up coyotes have a
different love language well he's just
trying to figure it out yes I
been and not Paxson from never have I
ever yes this well thank you
way to show up been does exist it's a
real you're pretty excited about this
yeah I like having out of the Dean been
over here you know we love it so I was
all about teen Ben but watching them
kiss did not keep me vibes it's hash tag
team Paxton packs and gotten screaming
Ben and me same oh now I get what last
episode is little devious but there's I
think the way the music was hittin
willing to driving to do me down things
really why I bring it into that song on
repeat okay that's a good song this
soundtrack to show like I boned to that
when I go in the car and I didn't know
any of the songs do you know a bad
soundtrack to ruin her show definitely
hit the market she getting great
something if you think about it no one
has ever put Ben gross first on his
parents his girlfriend not his friends
no one if this didn't bully drop
everything for Devi he put her first he
gave a sort of us live someone to talk
to you wow that was super deep and I am
really in the fields he peels back some
of that that layer of being rude and
stuff and then he's a kind boy he just
got a he's got show that side a little
bit more or thank you for putting that
in perspective um I like that dugout
admit Daxton Paxson waited for her to be
ready
meanwhile baby Ben tried to kiss Davey
Weiss at a party even though he has a
whole girlfriend not to mention Paxton
let baby into his life cautiously
because he was protecting his sis
I like that max know he comes off Jared
then you realize it comes from a good
place but it's the same we do there that
was also some cool thing about our shows
you see two different guys with two
different backgrounds handling things
every way into figuring out with
themselves to you know every but
everybody's got insecurities I like that
guy like you try to kiss her twice even
though you have a whole girlfriend the
thing that redeems it unless time it's
ever okay to cheat but like your
girlfriend Anna Stein she's awesome but
her character is absolutely geez be war
or students here is is
yes girlfriend I just watched the entire
season I never have I ever and I'm just
saying if she doesn't want packs and
I'll take someone's Darrin I do I do
hey you know so I guess I got options
rewatching never have I ever and I can't
believe that gave us Paxson Holly Ishita
Ben gross it's not a big sometimes you
know so I that's okay it's it you know
beauty is in the eye of the beholder you
got different choices I mean yeah yeah
Todd oh you got two potatoes you just
pick whichever one is that I think
Shakespeare said it
do you work effectively are you unable
to stop thinking about Paxton from never
have I ever
I can't do anything without thinking
about the accident why has changed my
life you know it's crazy right now
because I know I feel like the show
would have obviously done well without
horn Xena but like being in quarantine
people have watched it so much more
attend oblique was just it's great I
think being a source of joy like during
quarantine you know and and how many
people like be able to watch a show that
they can really relate to and and put a
smile on their face and watch it as many
times as they want okay so I'm watching
never have I ever and I'm confused how
I'm supposed to read the Paxton like
he's sweet but the enemy's two lovers
are but Ben and baby is the lane flame
I've never used that before but I'm
going to I like it I just want to like
flash forward 10 20 years it's you know
Davey and Ben when they're looking back
like you remember in the hallway gave
you when I used to comment on your
mustache I wanted I didn't have one look
at it now you guys still just probably
roasting each other in the future it's a
good dynamic duty unfair that boring-ass
Ben got his episode he now has everyone
really bad room where's my Paxton
episode I'm there for it season 2 ending
a season to be doing situps and skate in
the whole episode that's the entire
thing but I really enjoyed your episode
net and you killed it you crushed it
look at the name Paxton hayashida and
named Ben gross I'll tell me what you
notice you do have a cool name though
and that story is awesome that you got
the the - Yoshida I love that story dude
given that was it that was a crazy thing
because as you know
Jared I originally I was Paxton Hall um
at the typical preppy white heartthrob
kid right and so I was speaking in
Japanese with you go and I knew by her
name she Japanese so I asked her she
spoke Japanese and we started conversing
and then salgo debate the wardrobe
designer he told Mindy and then Lang
came up to me being like hey were you
speaking to Japanese and Yuko and I
think I've told you this and I thought I
was in trouble for a minute I knew that
not many people knew I was far Jeff
needs you know I'm like ambiguous but
they're like she came up to me she was
like ooh she is you go and I'm like yeah
but like she said it was cool like we
kinda know she was like you know like
it's Jo but then just you know she's
like oh are you part chef knees yeah I
am and then immediately she do you mind
if we making character projects and I
didn't know they were gonna run with it
until we went to the next table read and
I saw - 82 ashita at the end of my name
but it's interesting man I was really
nervous about it it's an identity I've
always had a struggle with and it's kind
of a pocket that I'm filling and like
representing in terms of like there's
many people like me that you can't solve
what they are and they're very proud of
their heritage and then when they say it
people will either don't leave it or
they're like they question it you know
yeah um so it was cool because I feel
like that's a pocket that I'm someone
representing I will tell you
Geron the best thing you know in
Japanese okay what Gotti must sing
pretty monitor means yeah you gotta know